oh man I'm so excited for this I love
this movie this is the kind of movie
that reminds me why I love movies it's
smart it's well-written it's touching
the characters are engaging and there's
a lot to talk about so let's do this
ladies and gentlemen source code so
there's been no small bit of confusion
over the decision to include this in
video game movie theme month since it
you know isn't an adaptation of a video
game and video games don't feature
prominently in the plot so I think I
should explain why we picked it this
actually goes back to crank 2 in that
review we talked about how the film's
narrative arc mirrors that of most video
games the important point was the games
tend to create dramatic tension through
gameplay failure where the player
outside the story fails to accomplish
the goals but set before them and must
retry the scenario until they executed
successfully crank 2 represented that
narrative arc stripped of the external
failure and this is where source code
comes into the discussion source codes
narrative conceit borrows the mechanics
of video games in order to deliver a
legitimately unique story that's equal
parts mystery and puzzle game well not
explicitly culled such captain Colter
Stevens is thrust into a game every time
he sent into the source code so before
we can get any further we need to get on
the same page with all that techno
babble and stuff because this is a film
with a mystery and plot twists and all
that jazz if you don't want to be
spoiled
well I'm sorry captain Colter Stevens is
an army helicopter pilot who gets blown
up while on a mission in Afghanistan the
army reports him is dead and the Air
Force hooks him up to an experimental
system called source code in a project
named beleaguered castle source code the
machine was invented by dr. Rutledge and
is helmed by Captain Goodwin it allows
them to send a person's consciousness
into the last eight minutes of someone's
life how they do this isn't explained in
detail and the details are frankly
unimportant what is the source code
quantum mechanics pair about calculus
it's a it's very complicated
that's not to say that everything about
source code is unimportant since there
are some very important game mechanics
involved it's just that the science of
how source code works doesn't matter in
this case which is the first outing of
the source code project captain Stevens
was sent into the life of Sean Fentress
a professor of history who was riding a
commuter train into Chicago when it
exploded killing all on board his goal
is to discover the identity of the
bomber in order to prevent a nuclear
bomb from being set off in Chicago the
bulk of the movie is spent alternating
between the real world and the source
code as Stephens pieces together the
puzzle of the Train and the reality of
his condition at the start of the film
he thinks he's in the cockpit of some
kind but slowly learns that he's
technically dead as far as the world is
concerned in the source code he develops
a relationship with Christina the film's
love interest and in the real world he
argues with Goodwin and Rutledge about
the morality of his situation in short
he gets to know Christina then gets
blown up he finds the bomb then gets
blown up he tries to get his hands on a
gun then gets blown up he assaults some
people then gets blown up he chases a
man into the station then gets hit by a
train he gets blown up then gets blown
up again then gets blown up a few more
times after that just for good measure
before he goes in again he cuts a deal
with Rutledge that they'll pull the plug
on him and let him die once the mission
is over they agree he goes in figures
out that Derek Frost is the bomber
confronts him and gets himself in
Christina shot in a parking lot back in
the real world he tells Goodwin and
Rutledge about frost they call it in to
the authorities frost is arrested
Rutledge reneged on the deal Goodwin
betrays Rutledge and sends Stevens in
one last time so he can try and save
everyone train he pulls it off
flawlessly mocks the bomber calls his
dad pays Russell Peters to do a stand-up
routine kisses Christina Goodwin pulls
the plug and Stevens lives on in Sean
Fentress body happy endings for everyone
there's a little bit more after that but
we'll come back to it first off why
throw this into a series about video
game movies simply put source code is a
game how do I get off saying that he's
playing a game well for that we have to
look at what makes something a game so
strap in because we're about to get good
Frenchie with our definitions here games
are sets of rules these rules can be
generally divided into three kinds the
board the procedures and the goals goals
are self-explanatory there are the
things that the player wants to
accomplish in order to bring the game to
a close
ideally winning procedures are all the
things you normally think of when you
hear about rules what counts as a valid
move what are the penalties for a
violation scoring systems and so forth
I'll fall into this category
the board is the defined limitations of
the game system and can actually be a
lot of different things board games have
a literal board sports have a field
video games have the game world card
games have a starting layout and
role-playing games have a communal
agreement of assumptions than the
foundational structure of character
generation there's one more important
characteristic and that's metaphor the
actions taken in the game are arbitrary
and symbolic they do not have intrinsic
external consequences that's important
because the entire point of a game is to
present the challenge of conflict
resolution without the actual risk in
fact most competitive games from chess
to football to Starcraft are really
simulations of war without the actual
killing of other people this all carries
over to source code the goal of the game
is to discover the bomber the board is
the Train the passengers the starting
position and the eight-minute time limit
the procedures well he's not actually
given many restrictions and this is
where the video game part of things come
in because the rules in a video game are
all handled by a computer many of the
overt procedures become invisible
there's no need for a list of illegal
moves or fouls when the programmers can
make it functionally impossible to cheat
you just can't drop an extra handful of
Marines into StarCraft while your
opponent is grabbing a sandwich in this
case captain Stevens is given free rein
to use whatever means he wants and the
only scoring is a binary pass/fail one
last point the intrinsic consequences
he's told repeatedly that his actions in
the source code have no impact on the
real world saving or killing someone in
the game doesn't save or kill them in
reality well but she survives and maybe
the rescue - he survived but only inside
the source code none
something I find really neat is that
this game metaphor isn't even something
that I'm overtly reading into all of
this remember what the name of the
program was what unit is this you're
with beleaguered castle well the project
named beleaguered castle comes from an
obscure version of solitaire this is
awesome script writing by the way the
whole reference is actually a
multi-layered metaphor first beleaguered
castle is a game second it refers to a
castle that's under attack in this case
Chicago is the castle and the attacks
are well yeah battle blowing up thing
third is the nature of the card game
itself in beleaguered castle the player
lays out the cards as such and then
moves them around in an attempt at
getting everything to stack properly in
the center it's not so much a game of
skill as it is a process of unravelling
a puzzle the trick is that the game is
incredibly difficult and most hands are
doomed to fail after only a few moves
the only way to actually win is to keep
playing hands until things work out see
the connection yet captain Stephens is
presented with a puzzle that's doomed to
end with an explosion and the only way
for him to win is to keep trying every
time he starts over the layout is the
same the players are the same the
setting is the same and the goal is the
same but changing variables change the
outcome of the game in the cards the
variable is the random dealing of the
deck in the film it's his changing
knowledge of the situation see now this
all of this this is good script writing
I just I I love it and I'm actually
going to cut this episode off here next
week we're going to talk about source
code again but we're going to have a bit
of fun with it
so next week the dark side of source
code on a mission
promise me you'll help him and when you
do do me a favor tell him everything is
gonna be okay
you